thank you all for being here this is a
great opportunity for us to be present
here strange loop about a song some
topics that we really excited about that
we've explored these last three months
our title is the idea is the machine
that makes the art that makes the
machine that makes the art and what that
really course exploring this topic is
exposing hidden layers and art
preservation and technical zine
forthcoming shout out to Amy for running
that workshop it was a lot of fun oh and
we have a lot of slides so some of it
might be really fast paced and if you
have questions reach out to us
afterwards first of all who are we
I'm Jonathan I do software and systems
engineering for a laboratory automation
company and I like to say that he makes
robots dance and I'm a product designer
and front an engineer and educator
neither of us are art historians um in
order do we use ml in our everyday life
so this is really going to be talked
about our exploration into some of how
we explore the data pipeline and
different ml techniques and finally how
this might apply to the artists all of
it
we're also two halves of a digital
practice that is striving to be both
prompt and pleasant and we're partners
in life I shouldn't be more excited
about that yes so we're really excited
about this talk we've had really
exciting enjoyable time working together
and particularly these last three months
you've enjoyed the the confluence of
machine learning art and philosophy and
over the this project our perception of
ml has changed
[Music]
so how did we get here this really
started with the call for presentations
a strange loop and we knew that we had a
burning desire to collaborate together
on a project outside work on a topic
that would combine both their systems of
thought and our different expertise so
Sol LeWitt was the first person that
came to mind for this talk just curious
look at the audience how many people out
there are familiar with Sol's work yeah
yeah that's that's really exciting so
we've really gone down the rabbit hole
of conceptual art and fallen deeply in
love with Saul in his work and
particularly with the the art practice
and his legacy so much so that our
journey culminated in a trip to the mass
MOCA in North oh yeah sorry North Adams
Massachusetts to see the incredible
showcase of his works on display there
and get a fuller appreciation of his
process - it's it's really incredible
that there's the generation-long
exhibit a hundred pieces of his work
that's up until 2033 we're new admirers
of Saul and his draft people's work yes
we're even cosplaying his wall drawings
right now so who was Saul Saul artists
who lived from 1928 to 2007 um he was
very prolific and we find that he's a
sage there are lots of words of wisdom
that most sprinkle through his talk I
mean our talk but maybe it's all because
of his based off of his ideas and he's
also known for founding two art
movements early on he what his sculpture
work was part of minimalism movement and
this is an example of cute without a
cube and later he was involved and
really a founding member of
conceptualism where he explored a lot of
questions of conceptual nature the such
very cute cans containing an object of
importance but a little value where he
asks hey if you don't actually see the
art to you is it art so this is the key
quote that kicked off this project in
conceptual art the idea or a concept is
the most important aspect of the work
when an artist uses a conceptual form of
art it means that all of the planning
and decisions are made beforehand and
the execution is a perfunctory affair
the idea becomes a machine that makes
the art and perfunctory meaning a from
earlier minimum of effort or reflection
but what a saw mean by this the idea
becomes a machine that makes the art as
we understand it he felt that all the
planning happened before you start
manipulating the media before pencil
hits paper before brush hits the canvas
or before fingers even hit the keys and
nonno was he a seminal figure and art he
was also an amazing person and this is
just one example that some of you may be
familiar with um it's his letter to Ava
Hess talking to her about how she's
amazing and how to get over some
apprehension she has with her art by
just getting over that hump and just
doing it
he was extremely humble he supported a
lot of different artists financially and
emotionally and sometimes financially
without them even knowing it and he was
a staunch supporter of women artists as
well and if you don't have time to read
the letter you can also see this
rendition by Benedict Cumberbatch which
is kind of astonishing too so here is a
piece and inspiring this whole endeavor
while drawing 797 we feel that it's a
perfect example of a wholly encapsulated
system it contains almost all the
ingredients necessary to install the
work itself and what do we mean by that
well this is not the full title so the
full title involves actually all the
instructions it takes to
perform this this piece and I'll briefly
go through it the first drafter has a
black marker and makes n a regular
horizontal line near the top of the wall
the second drafter tries to copy it
without touching it using a red marker
the third does the same with the yellow
the fourth with the blue and then they
repeat and so so always uh prototyped
instructions like these and tweak them
until he could get predictable results
but you can kind of think of them as
pseudocode for art which is kind of like
for conceptual art and it's pretty
incredible so these simple instructions
can create just an infinite array of
beautiful generative works where the
interactions between the different
drafters as well as the the first line
that's that's placed on the wall to the
physical wall that's installed on have
huge effects on the outcome of the of
the piece and this core idea that that's
all had so he said I had the idea that
if you can pass on the instructions from
one person to another that they can draw
a line or a group of lines or different
kinds of lines or exit cetera and this
idea is still true and truly anyone can
do it
so looking at this example one the
materials that Saul like to use for a
fairly accessible materials such as
crayons pencils or markers and in some
cases and you ink which is a pretty
common ink the wall drawings based off
of these instructions are very
site-specific so each location looks a
little bit different and interestingly
enough any drawing that's made from
these instructions no matter who does it
in his words is still thought to be a
solloway so this goes back to idea that
the idea is the core piece in that
artwork another interesting aside is
that even though he thought that anyone
could install these and they could be
bonafide Sol LeWitt's they couldn't be
sold unless they had a certificate that
it was associated with them we couldn't
find one for 797 but this one's for
or 550 541 and these certificates cannot
be issued previously without Saul's
consent but now without the consent of
this state and this is what it actually
looks like in Virginia Museum all right
so based off of not drawing we decided
to create our first prototype the first
part of the data pipeline for us so we
created a prototype with react p5.js no
GS with the intent of using a pinnacle
trick to get a lot of human input and
have all these people together create
one while drawing and then put all that
information into our model - great a
very generalized I'm all drying and this
is the result our first prototype wasn't
what we expected it to be and we are
sorely disappointed but we persevered we
tweaked and refined and continued to
test between the two of us which turned
into this which is a lot closer to what
they actually look like in real life the
texture to get used with it took about
30 minutes to complete each one and
actually our arms would get sore using
the trackpad on our computer which is a
strange constraint yes we got um we had
to take breaks and we had to take mental
breaks too because it can get very
repetitive and in some cases boring but
then eventually you reach this barrier
where because meditative again I hope
it's but then it felt like our old
pipeline was a little bit more like
dream so we we didn't even feel
comfortable getting our friends to sit
down and draw with us and it just didn't
feel practical use something like
mechanical trick because we also wanted
to pay people at least living wage and
that meant 25 cents or more per minute
and it also included training and it
included having to assess it it's and if
someone wasn't drying the way we had
expected we'd have to ask them to coach
back to drawing board
it just it was too much overhead so
despite this grand vision of human
assistance the human assistance would be
just us but that it was actually really
good thing because it allowed us to make
more nuanced models which we'll revisit
a little bit later in it and it turns
out us all had a similar idea then that
although anybody can do the kinds of
lines that are very precisely a few
people can do them well and that
training is really important and so
doing individual lines from a lot of
different individuals may not have been
the approach anyway so we put a wall
drawing 797 on the back burner for a
little bit and looked at other wall
drawings we collected a 1,300 different
varieties of wall drawings the text for
them which were done in 35 oh sorry
um actually we has over 1300 varieties
of wall drawings that have been
installed 3500 times and more called
hundred locations okay so here we go
here we get to the point where we
thought about generating new wall
drawings from using LS TM and tensorflow
and here's where we collected a 250 yeah
of the wall drawings and we started
generating some fun things and some of
the results are actually pretty good
especially if you didn't really look too
hard at them like number seven oh and we
use the index of at what
they were generated to give them the
number like wall drawings kind of and so
number seven square for vertically into
four equal parts first part on blue
white horizontal parallel lines and in
the center irregular parallel figure
random some needed a bit more work I
really like four-star though it sounds
like a really exciting way to start to a
wall like good job a geometric paper I
like that too mm-hmm a little too
conceptual even for us so revisiting our
data set we really wanted to we just
started looking at you know why we're
things a little bit I guess off and he
doesn't have a whole lot of variance in
his titles so we kind of was a play on
trying to figure out how do you not just
completely replicate exactly what he's
what he's made and overtrained that the
model and over time he also got to the
point where his pieces didn't have the
much instructions in them they were just
things like splat and there's not as
much to learn off of at that point we
thought that mark hi Markov chains might
be a good way to overcome this but at
this point we still felt we were
straying a little bit from solloway
giving a look at the drawings that were
just generated so we started looking at
other ways to apply saw like a euro
style transfer but the hair just like no
like given the thoughtfulness that Saul
has in his work
transferring Saul's style to other works
just wasn't the right way to go also a
lot of people are doing it which made us
think you know we were just doing ml for
MLS sake
so like other things there's a song
quote for that he said new materials are
one of the great afflictions of
contemporary art some artists confuse
the materials with new ideas and and I
was kind of in that in that room so this
kind of got into the realm for us of we
started to think about like what were
the balance of the power of Mo a machine
learning and what which problems is it
appropriate to utilize the power of it
and where is it weak and we thought
about using it now more deeply and
looked at other artists using it in a
meaningful way so our first example is
sue Gwen and she trained a neural net
off of her previous archive work and
then is feeding it through a robot so
that she can make work with it
collaboratively we have Tom white who
was trying to create general adversarial
networks or gans to fool image net by
creating works in real life so he had to
train these other adversarial networks
to take into consideration how these
prints would look as they went through
the physical process of being printed
some of the what is it called miss
printings and also how they might be the
so when you look at them at different
angles they would still be able if you
took a photo of them at different angles
they would still be able to fool
imagenet and to thinking that's a toilet
or I think my favorite is the tricycle
another great example on music is Holly
Herndon I mean she and her partner are
working a train an AI baby it's about
two years old and they've been training
it on their own voices as well as the
voices and their Ensemble and they feel
like it's already starting to learn
you're talking sing which is really
scary for them
well maybe not scary but I think they're
they were a little surprised by that
recently it's credited as being a singer
on one of their tracks yes when Holly
Herndon is new record and also uh MIMO
Acton so to pull from the artists page
directly he opens with a quote we see
things not as they are but as we are and
he describes this project learning to
see as an artificial neural network
looks out on the world trying to make
sense of what it sees in the context of
what it has seen before you can only see
what it already knows just like us
that one's incredible you should
definitely take a look if you don't know
about it so just thinking again are we
still doing this work in honor of Saul
are we doing this for ourselves you're
super inspired but at the same time like
what would Saul want to do with his work
and what wouldn't Saul actually do with
his work and doing a little bit more
research as we understand it Saul always
wanted his work to look contemporary so
that's the reason why he chose these
colors and the geometric shapes and why
he tested things time and time again
before he made instructions but to make
it contemporary it also means
reinstalling over time because these
materials as archival as it could be
they're still in physical spaces and
they still get interacted with which can
cause damage to them and Saul and all of
his drafts people wanted generations to
enjoy his work but the first aha moment
came from this panel between several
Saul's assistants or drafts people will
kind of use this term those two terms
interchangeably from that lecture we
learned that some of his drafts people
have been it with him from the start
almost 40 years that's 40 years of
knowledge and it reflects this thought
that Saul had which was that any
assistant or kossmann or crafts person
could be very good and sometimes better
at different tasks and the artists
themselves and
not only have they been with him for 40
years there have been multiple
generations of assistance so on the
right left on the left and wait you're
right right who's right you'll see John
Hogan who is one of his original
assistants and as we look deeper into
understanding of Saul's intent we found
this quote where he says art is made by
human beings not machines which how do
we bring that back to machine learning
so so yeah and how do we honor the
humans in this process so we thought
about a really capturing the knowledge
of generations of Saul's drafts people
the the conceptual aspects of in of art
are more difficult to model with AI and
really would require a more generalized
intelligent intelligence which I think
we'll get to eventually with some models
but I don't think we're there today but
something that came out of this process
is that narrow visual and mechanical
concepts can be modeled but such as
aesthetically pleasing irregular lines
or the execution of a process which
brings us to washes which we tried
several different approaches with these
including a CNN auto-encoder but we
settled eventually on on something
called picks - picks but just to make
sure we're on the same page here's what
we mean by washes so revisiting this
picture notice the texture in the
background of the lines that those are
the washes those blocks of the shapes
and this is a zoomed in version on
another piece of the washes and Saul's
drafts people have a very specific
process they use a certain brand of
painted ink that was approved by Saul
and it's diluted down to a certain
viscosity to make it applied in a
certain way and repeatable and then they
apply like even washes like washing a
car over the wall and then they do this
thing - may actually make the texture
which I really like called boom-boom and
for each layer of color it's
- seven layers each so they have like
already a very replicable process and
here's what the gray piece looks like up
close
so what are we trying to do here
we chose the model a very small
seemingly simple problem to assist
knowledge transfer between assistants
thinking about the washes and how would
you train an assistant in the future we
wanted to capture a model of experience
dress graphs people to help train future
and help maintain knowledge across
generations
so in p5 you're able to like code up
something that quickly approximates a
texture these washes but how do you
actually capture the decision-making
process when it comes to aesthetics so
like how would a draftsperson I look at
this and say like oh this parts good
this is bad this tool wasn't necessarily
made to replicate the most perfect model
of a assistant that's hard it's hard for
anyone to describe why they like certain
things and also narrows the
possibilities of that algorithm so
instead this is what we use for the core
of our data production and then we
allowed for us to identify areas that to
us as individuals looked like they
needed more work and overtime so
previously this is from the UI and then
as we trained a neural net with lots of
different washes this is what the net
actually described as being off for my
model so it's kind of cool that's pretty
close to that bottom left area and so to
make this kind of feel complete we
wanted to take it back and apply it to
real washes so we took photos of real
washes and ran it on them and this shows
some places where we thought there were
some issues but that's really a
difference in aesthetic compared to the
assistants since this is a final piece
so kind of shows that we
not the correct training set right and
just a stress this was our model not us
so the other benefit of creating a
machine learning model as compared to
trying to code it is that this idea of
continuous / improvement so over time as
one gains knowledge of the washes or
their own aesthetic or understanding of
Sol's work likely their assessment of
the washes will change and as you
continue to feed that into the model the
model will update as well other thing is
creating a perfect algorithm on the
onset is time-consuming and will likely
only update every now and then like
every few decades and a model instead
could learn as time goes on so how do
you apply this to all drawing 797 well
as described earlier we had to focus
more on our individual data sets and it
helped us think about machine learning
in a different way so with the
mechanical trigger model we were
thinking of having lots of different
assistants come together and every
assistant would contribute to kind of
like this monolithic model all their
inputs creates different weights and
combines into this like amorphous blob
of model that you see up there but the
once we started thinking about
individualized models and I'm sure
there's terms for this so if you can let
us know what they are after the talk
we'd love to hear them this kind of
emerged as you're like oh how do we ml
and these individualized models like the
one touch with the washes helped us
really figure out how we might apply
this to Sol's assistance so but first we
we took the learning from our learnings
from the washes back to into the wall
drawing exploration and trained to
networks one on each of us so this is a
drawing generated by Christine
[Music]
and the tool that Christine created
there which show uses the whole drawing
but the tool captured individual lines
and as such we could create a mapping
between subsequent lines well where the
line on the left is the input right is
the output and beneath the hood as you
can see from the screenshot above we
broke it into tonnes of component lines
and generated a train the model on train
a model of hers and a model of mine on
on data sets like this like with the
washes we tried some different ml
approaches but ultimately my tone picks
the pics again this is the result of
Chris Christie's model completing an
entire wall drying based on just one
human input which is the black line at
the top which we found really exciting
and it even got the colors right which I
was really pumped about um so oh also
when putting together the output I had
to like multiply the lines to
superimpose them and you can kind of see
like small areas where it shows that I
overlapped which kind of was exciting to
me because it showed that the algorithm
is kind of learning my mistakes as well
[Music]
and we were super pumped by those
results but we also saw this quote by
one of Saul's other oldest assistants
Joe Watanabe basically to paraphrase he
felt that copies of Saul's work really
didn't achieve the right outcome and
that was at odds with something he said
later which was that he also he
recognizes that but he also wants to
have infinite assistance making infinite
drawings and infinite locations so how
do we do that how do you bridge those
two ideas so again we took a step back
and we looked at different ways to
preserve culture such as new Palmira
which is trying to reconstruct buildings
in Syria in 3d space Notre Dom there is
like it was lucky that someone had
actually captured the entire space
so that people can reconstruct from it
but also thinking about artists like
sequin and Holly who are actively
trading their own models on them but how
do we train a model on Sol who's no
longer with us
Saul and his assistants are in this
unique position where we can kind of
capture the knowledge through them
because they're really the people who
are inseparable from the work and they
informed a lot of the technique behind
Saul's work and if we were thinking
about cultural preservation the hope is
that with well-trained models we can
prevent instances of a well-meaning
restoration like this which is supposed
well it was a restoration or a priceless
depiction of Christ in Spain but
something went awfully Ryan in the
restoration process
Saul didn't just have one assistant he
had many and and he has many or he has
many yes and many assistants have
certain specialties and unique knowledge
so we thought there's a good time to
revisit the types of models that we sort
of discussed earlier the monolithic
versus the individualized and do a
comparative analysis mm-hmm so this is
our joint like training data that we
generated so our original drawings
directions mines on the left and jeonse
is on the right and if we look at mine
versus John's mine are a little bit more
organic his are more jagged my lines are
closely packed his are spaced out when
we compare models they reflect the same
sort of aesthetics but they have
different outputs than what we had
already it's exciting because this is my
model on the left and John's on the
right on the same line as before and but
uh so look at this we actually did
something really fun where we got our
models to collaborate together and this
really blew us away we like use
somebody's line then the next person's
model then alternated models all the way
down
and it's really fun to see see the
output from this like that it actually
gets the the bands of like differences
between us yeah for example you can
clearly see or at least to us that my
lines are much closer to the previous
lines whereas John's are much further
away and it kind of helps us get to the
multi assistant approach so like imagine
being able to capture joe watanabe is
aesthetic and then john Hogan's
aesthetic and future generations could
kind of look at these models for advice
they're not necessarily meant to get
prescriptive feedback on how they should
make the ball drawings but they could be
a way to capture some of that knowledge
without a lot of upfront work yep and
it's just cool to see them work together
a little bit against each other in a
beautiful harmonious way just pushing
and pulling the the overall output and
different ways and not all of them
worked well together but I actually
really like this cuz it's kind of like
our models arguing as they try and
figure out this like chaotic input that
they weren't necessarily trained on and
we it only took the completion of six
drawings from each of us to train these
models which was a lot less than we
expected and these are just four so that
you can see the detail as we compare the
different approaches on the left side
are mine
and on the right side are John's and
again this is just a fun thing for us to
realize picks up picks is amazing and
we're gonna just show you a quick
progression between the different
applications of the models so again this
is the source models and these are our
own models with our own lines
and these are our models with each
other's lines so the status kind of
switched sides mm-hmm and these are our
models collaborating together so it's
it's interesting to see how the Michigan
Learning Assistance could collaborate to
create like a almost act approach but in
the future perhaps two assistants are
really good at identifying the right
lines but another one is great at that
starting line you could train different
models of like wait them differently and
combine them later additionally these
combinations provide reminded us of how
it's all like to combine different
components of his work and could be
something we explore in the future to
see how the different combinations would
inform aesthetic yes and I think we're
gonna start breezing through the rest of
our slides here so although while
drawing 797 is relatively easy to
install with this marker uh-huh quotes
from his assistants suggest otherwise is
like differ hands-on hurt we're not
doing a good job and here's like some
more insight into that like these are
very large wall drawings one of his
recent installations of 100 drawings
took six months with 65 assistants and
there's a long process of treating the
walls prepping the space I think some
people said they hadn't liked draw like
continuously like even past the point of
wanting to quit cuz it hurts so much but
it's also like creates this beautiful
output it's also worth noting that this
was installed after Saul's death and he
never saw the outcome of it which is a
testament to how much he trusted in his
uh-huh so we thought it liked help these
assistants how might we automate this
process just so future generations could
enjoy Saul's work and keep things
keeping
contemporary is expensive and passing
knowledge might be difficult in a
traditional sense
so although it's all believed that art
is made by human beings he also embraced
new technologies he was open to trying
them if his assistants would be still
able to achieve the original intent and
they changed methodologies several times
with lots of different forms like from
straying to laser levels and for us so
we just sort of thought if a human
generates the input would it be
reasonable to solve for a bot to execute
the output and so we explored scribbles
of paper J s an Arduino and polar graph
and this is what we mean by scribbles or
like pretty random lines so we kind of
generated that in our tool and then this
is just a more simple approach so you
can kind of see how those lines kind of
interact with each other and we also
developed this plotter rigged to test a
or we actually installed this this raid
to test our concepts in our apartment
we we thought it might be a fun thing to
as a to use a tool to help with some of
the more difficult tasks of making
scribbles a side benefit is that it
brings a mechanism is a it's a mechanism
to bring the art back into the physical
world so here's a drawing in our
apartment tada calibration stole off the
house this is supposed to be a square
but it's like a good starting point so
where do we go from here
so can we combine the model and the
robot and humans it's like kind of where
we we want to go is our next steps yes
an amazing rendering of what it might
look like installed on our wall so but
we're still leftist and brain questions
so how do we validate that these models
actually captured us and that they
captured our essence our aesthetic and
our intentions is there enough
randomness to encapsulate the variations
of us as individuals
but then on the same token is that even
necessary so like the approach with
these models is to seek advice from the
past and with advice you don't
necessarily need to take it and they're
not this like a necessity to the
everyday practice like these very small
what is it vant like advantage points
into Sol's process and another question
we have is like generations from now at
what point when an m/l trained team of
assistants stray very far away from
solid initial vision but potentially you
could just keep his initial assistants
models around so yeah we'd like to kind
of get there the viewpoint of the
assistants and try to understand that
and see how maybe if they'd be
interested in transferring ml knowledge
so finally you wanted to end on this
quote I've always worked out here if I
had a show coming up I'm like basically
you I had to do something and this is
kind of like the end of our journey if
you have the opportunity to present and
you want to work and hovering on
something with someone you like but also
it was also a harrowing process you
should definitely do it it's wonderful
it's it's beautiful and a little scary
but you know transfer that terror into
excitement and it's an experience will
draw a lot from yeah and a shout out to
conferences like strangely which kind of
make it a more accessible by covering
travel on board as well and other shout
outs really quickly to my dad who helped
us a little bit with a printer printing
Greg and my sister and our partner for
helping us focus on this project
and of course those saw and all his
assistants for the core of this thank
you yeah thank you
you